we are back in applications of calculus
to the physical world right now you
might recall a couple weeks ago we
looked at two of the subtopics the first
two parts of applications and cutters of
this blog what were those two parts
number one rates of change and second
late exponential growth in detail now
you might recall relative change is
really to the topic exponential Griffin
cake mostly it's your topic with a
little bit of extension one it the
reason we started razor change was well
may I should ask what kinds of questions
what kind of scenarios did we encounter
in that topic remember there's pretty
brief sorry yeah coffee what about
coffee oh yeah okay I think was that
exponential decay I feel like that was
exponential growth and decay but that's
okay it's still it's still the same kind
of idea we lump them together because
there's a temperature it changes sure
what else what else okay so the idea
channel is how we approach each of the
questions because wherever there are
rates that are related to each other use
change your channel to change the
variable what kind of examples are we
thinking of though like we have a cup of
coffee what else okay we we talked about
sand right a pile of sand that was
growing and we talked about a tank of
water that was emptying out um yeah any
other sugar ok a population that was
smiling up or dropping down ok so all
these kinds of things really are the
courses way of saying calculus good
morning calculus really is the
mathematics of change and it's about 80
quantity that changes ok but importantly
the two quantities that we are that
we've historically and practically the
most interested in comparing question to
change our position and time which in a
word is about motion right objects
moving over time now a lot of people
essentially over the years I've been
teaching this ah motion this is why I
did it study physics like I don't know
how to do this and like Dwight do I have
to go through all this kind of all this
language all these ideas and the answer
is yes sir no um the the yes is what
clearly physics is very very interested
in
okay but at the same time physics and
emotion in a mathematical tastes are
very very different so I thought because
I've been trying to spend years trying
to wrap my head around this and we did
this for extension two volumes as well I
want you to understand the way that
these topics particularly motion had
physics relate to each other and are
different remember we just said calculus
in the physical world we've looked at
good morning grab one of these why do I
have so few I should have had exactly
enough is anyone got spares that
actually puts pairs of your process I
ever did I got it exactly right okay you
just lost that's all in calculus in the
physical world right I want us to
remember but two things we've just
looked at most recently our rates of
change to change and what I'm going to
call we wear been calling an exponential
growth of decay but really what it is is
natural growth and decay right in the
natural world things grow and they decay
in proportion to their size or in
proportion to their difference from some
quantity for example their difference to
the art via temperature okay so these
are these two ideas here right when we
have a look at motion which again is own
subtopic we're really thinking about two
particular things with the emotion and
I'm going to kind of cover tune
extension one and extension to the same
time because all fits together so dry
yourself a line a dotted line kind of
down the middle here the first thing
we're going to look at is and this is
mainly in tuna three unit is called
kinematics kinematics that's where the
cane right the topic the area the the
study of kinematics is all about how are
things moving how are things moving
you'll have an object or several objects
and all you want to ask about is in what
manner is its position changing with
respect to time how is it moving that's
the question okay so under this idea of
relating
position and time there are three key
concepts and you'll all have heard of
these ideas before but we're going to
dig into each of them so when we talk
about ok where is something what is its
position the important idea for us is
displacement now a displacement is a
world which has armed many meanings in
many different contexts but for us the
idea is how far have you been displaced
moved away from where you've begun ok
now this is all about like when we said
our rate of change right this is not
just a subtopic this is the whole thing
everything is about rates of change so
when displacement is changing when your
position is changing over time that's
such an important idea we give its own
name we call it velocity velocity is how
displacement is changing over time but
again we want to be interested in how
that's changing is well how's your
velocity changing as time changes and we
give that another name as well we call
it acceleration so these three concepts
displacement velocity acceleration they
are all that answer to the question
you've got an object a particle a point
how is it moving you describe that to be
okay now kinematics is very closely
related to but different to mechanics
these bought both fall under motion and
by the way I should say I'm sort of
broadly oversimplifying this idea but
I'm trying to get to the heart of what
makes these things different mechanics
isn't so much interested in how
something is moving it's more
interesting the question of why is it
moving in that way it's doing that it's
moving back and forth and back and forth
or it's accelerating and accelerating
getting faster and faster forever or
getting slower and slower forever but
mechanics is trying to ask the question
why is it moving like that why is it
moving in that particular fashion why is
the particle the object behaving in the
way that it is okay so underneath the
heading of mechanics and this is where
extension to students will kind of take
over there are two important ideas which
we don't have to worry about as tuna and
extension one students those two ideas
are how heavy is something that kind of
has a really really big impact on why is
it moving in the way that it
moving and also what things are
influencing that object we call those
forces right so things like gravity or
air resistance or whatever medium you're
in these are all exerting forces on your
object which therefore affect your
acceleration effective velocity
affecting your spaceman ok